交通事故
おっぱあと
いっ
を知った
あーなんてこった親今日も返済できることを考えついてしまったそうクジラに見えます
のは中に今のあのあれがありますと説明しではわかると思うんですけどもの時だけ簡単
高速振動のエクササイズができるベルトを買いましたほか米前1個開けてみません
こちらの竜アブドル web っていうなんか余裕あの
よくテレビとかで見ると思うんですけども今もわかる書見て肌とかに細くんですよあけ
マット個つけるだけでスイッチを on にすると思う
めっちゃ振動して1分間に5000回転の協力サイトのでシェイプアップということで
これをつけるだけで筋肉が鍛えられるというものがありますまあこれ一つで
エクササイズができるということなんですけどもな天才の俺が考えた幌やっぱり
歳だから忙しい理由時間が全くないそんな俺でもね簡単にエクササイズをしょうちゃん
時間でできる方法が張っておりますそう
入ってんでもうめっちゃ笑ってるんですよねそう今ちょっと見学者が来てるとしっかり
見て覚えておけばぞ
ここで身につけたことを仕事に活かすんだ
メジャーって行けないじゃんとネクタイとベルト今日は10にくかったんですけども
これを一気にこれを体につけるとた仕掛けで5000は
4万ぐらいかな4万がパチかける5戦の4万スター400回転なんです41600回転
これは全部カードに身につけると文化が1分間な41600回転ができるというね
もう驚異の駅舎サイズにがこれを使って俺が多分一週間ぐらいトレーニングするとも
精神の時の飢餓状態になっちゃうわけ
バイオ株するだけでもうみんなが頑張ってる
を使ってする10番以上の力で俺はもう筋肉ついてるわけなんで短時間の間に一気に
ムキムキになると思いますでは神日に馬いるよ
ああ
ほすげーたちの今日はケースまだ入ってるよこれを体中にぜんぶつけて全部電源 on
にして一気にムキムキになりますそれでは
中電
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
バーグウェイ
すごいれ
じゃないよ
あっときちゃう
見るわからない労働局まで払いたいこれいったが違ってっ
私は今じゃんってちゃってこれやばいコツ電気的な刺激タイプなんで本当に痛い奴よ
一人で全部別の準備完了したので身体につけていきます
me
終わったろーはろー
スバル来ないっしょはいえーと全然接続環境したのであとは全粒を流すだけです
ではやってみましょう一分間して4判160ページ祭典
先にこの小さいの時つけておこう
これはそれを開き対策世界キャンプだした落としたこそ
ん
合うタイプ連絡しましたましたーーー
さあ著書あやばい鉄骨今の30
安全日なてやってきた yoshiki さんやすい本
can you do j
jarod l 2
re a
den o o
al